oh boy do we have a lot to get to I got
a jump right in joining me now
exclusively is the president's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani mayor great to
see you sorry not in the studio but we
got some major breaking news we need to
get to in just truants but first your
reaction to the Democrats asking build
bar to an essence violate the legal
boundaries of reviewing this report for
grand jury confidential information the
subpoena vote today was along party
lines but they're throwing down the
gauntlet what's what's your reaction
well I think they're actually proving
that they're a bit basically rabid
partisan Democrats who should not be
investigating something where you have
to have some degree of objectivity and
fairness before you call people before
committees they obviously have none they
have no regard for the Constitution or
the laws I can show you letters from
them that would be a joke in terms of
total disregard for the attorney-client
privilege as if it doesn't exist and now
they want the Attorney General to
violate rule 60 which is a federal
felony five years in prison and they'd
like him to to violate possibly or was a
regarding classification possibly
damaged innocent reputations the reality
is I am absolutely confident that the
Attorney General will put out a very
very complete part if not all of it
whatever he can legally and maybe they
should change the law if they want to
and so that every grand jury or grand
jury testimony is just open to everybody
and there's no attorney-client privilege
maybe maybe we can do away with you know
they get away with the presumption of
absence for about two years so their
disregard for the Constitution is
mind-boggling and frightening yeah well
they didn't want any this released when
it was 98 and was a Star report they
don't want that realize now it's a
different deal but they claim that look
the president initially said he wants it
all out and now they're kind of pulling
back on that so you know the perfect
simplistic message is what do you have
to hide well first of all the president
actually can't have it all out either he
overriding the law he can't say okay the
grand jury secrecy doesn't matter only a
judge can do that under very very narrow
circumstances you know that Laura
these people are lawless they're a joke
I mean it there are laws in this country
Republicans get the benefit of laws not
just Democrats oh Rudy the New York
Times just reported hours ago and and
the left is going gaga over this that
the Muller team members think that their
findings are more damaging for Trump
then barmaid out in his summary
four-page letter now they've
conveniently leave out which team
members they have an issue with it seems
like they've they've kind of you know
there were a lot of Democrat loyalists
and that team but it seems that they're
there maybe they're feeling the heat or
they want to put something else out
there but does this seem to be a
politically motivated grievances well
first of all it makes the point that
we've been making for two years despite
all of the media reports about how holy
and sanctimonious the Moller team is
they're they're a bunch of sneaky
unethical leakers and they are rapid
Democrats who hate the President of the
United States and I can't tell you how
much false information they leaked
during the course of the investigation
how many people were going to be
indicted that didn't get indicted how
many how many blockbusters were there
starting with Papadopoulos and ending
with Cohen who turns out to be a serial
liar I mean it's a how could you have
any confidence in this but I just had
Richard Goodstein on and you know he's a
lawyer well-known used to work for
Hillary he said look why why would they
all not tell him the full truth about
these contacts with Russians
they said the meeting was about adoption
and I looked at him and I liked Richard
I said are you still saying they're
collude are you that is the face that is
the full truth by the way the full truth
is the meeting was about the magnesia
and about adding adoption since I have
to that happens to be true they are
still clinging to the collusion thing
they have not let it go and they they
are they are they now think with this
New York Times report Rudy that they're
going to have their
gonna be stuff in this mullah report
they want it release like yesterday
they're in a big protest over the
country they claim tomorrow
they gotta release this thing now
unredacted all underlying documents and
you can see they've got to keep feeding
more on their beefs they got a key I am
absolutely confident that the the report
will bear out the conclusions the
conclusions no of no obstruction
no Russian collusion of any kind it will
bear that out
whether they can take some facts and
twist in one way or another we're ready
to rebut that I've been ready to rebut
their report for four months and Jay has
on our team asked and we would be happy
to take them on we think we can prove
beyond any doubt that there is nothing
to collusion and I don't even think
they're talking about collusion and I
think we can pull the exactly nothing to
obstruction Schiff said today on MSNBC
we don't the play I'll just read it he
said there's plenty of evidence of
collusion and corrupt commingling of
work between the Trump campaign and the
Russians he said that this morning on
Morning Joe well I mean I don't know if
there's anything left of Adams
reputation or anybody would believe him
but the reality is there is no evidence
of collusion because there was no
collusion and let me just give you one
overview of obstruction how could there
be obstruction when Muller completed his
investigation and nobody obstructed it
what did somebody think about
obstruction that's not a crime I mean
they're clearly mothers the proof is in
the what kind of obstruction was this
MOA got 500 witnesses 1.4 million
documents spent upwards of 40 million
dollars got to his conclusion without
anybody interfering with him so God
Almighty this would be the strangest
obstruction case I ever saw hey Rudy
that's not obstruction
still gonna stay at the White House I
mean he's been doing this mother thing
for I mean I met flood is an old friend
of mine well Emmett flood is such a good
lawyer this isn't the only thing he does
he's a critical part of the president's
team I've had the honor of working with
him I think he's a great lawyer and he's
one of the reasons we got the result
that we get you Betty
by the way I got a play out of chef he
just said this moment
ago Rudy and he must have known you were
coming on tonight let's watch why didn't
he release a summary produced by Bob
Muller himself instead instead of trying
to shape it through his own words so I
don't know what to make of the New York
Times report it is concerning we're
gonna fight this in any way we can and
any way we need to to make sure that the
American people get to see the product
of Bob Miller's work without the filter
of mr. Trump's hand-picked attorney
general no they are all the way through
2020 the hryvnas they're gonna write it
right right to making themselves even
more incredible than they are already
that man should be should be ashamed for
his disgraceful conduct in saying that
he had evidence of collusion where's the
evidence of collusion did you give it to
Muller of course you didn't because you
weren't telling the truth you're not
telling the truth now you're such a
overwhelmed partisan you're so emotional
in your hatred of Trump you can't even
see the truth Rudy the the issue of the
tax returns came up again today that the
House Democrats you know formally
requested six years of the president's
personal and business tax returns we
knew this was going to come right and
they want them ok so just you have a pen
they want them a week from today here
was the president's response today
moments ago asked the IRS for six years
of your tax returns looky here is that
all that's all Oh
usually it's ten so I guess they're
giving up now I'm we're under audit I
despite what people said and we're
working that out this ludicrous but why
does being under audit preclude him from
releasing his tax rate well the real
reason is that this is not the IRS
Nadler is completely distorting our
government this is not an enforcement
agency they don't get to look at my tax
return I mean a congressional committee
doesn't get to look at my tax return or
yeah it's coming from Ways and Means
going right to the IRS are actually not
asking Trump they're going to the IRS
unprecedented unprecedented in the IRS
we could have to resist it because it'd
be totally illegal there's no basis for
it there's no legislative basis for it
and they're not the IRS they don't
investigate tax fraud or tax
irregularities or tax mistakes if they
start investigating that we're gonna
this everybody got all upset with Nixon
did this this is horrendous if Congress
if these politicians in Congress can get
the hands on people's tax returns and
they go after you know they're Democrats
and they go after Republicans tax
returns what have we become it has to be
resisted the president has to resist
this for the good of all of us because
otherwise they'll be going after you
know that they get a media person who is
too far right they'll go after their tax
returns all right Rudy and apparently
tomorrow they're gonna be subpoenaing
the greenskeeper at mar-a-lago at the
golf course well and the orange
bedsheets that go the only thing I'm
worried about is did President Trump
when he was younger pay all those
parking tickets I think he did I think
he did I think it's the best we have
story is the best that's their shifting
an hour on the golf game
all right Rhodey thank you so much we
love you